ich kann jetzt auch nur drauf gucken in
der Erwartung dass das jetzt schnell
gelöst wird so ich aber es geht so nicht
Punkt so das geht und es ist ja der
Eindruck entstanden also voraus hat sich
ja geäußert dass es nicht darum ging
jetzt das eine zu stoppen um das andere
noch irgendwie zu verhandeln zwei Tage
später gesagt ich kann es nicht bewerten
am Ende zählt für mich dass diese Dinge
jetzt schnell verabschiedet werden aber
der Staat nach der nach der Sommerpause
den hatte ich mir anders vorgestellt das
hätte uns gut getan wenn dieser Staat
anders ist und deswegen habe ich diese
deutlichen Worte auch gefunden und es
gibt auch keine Entschuldigung für aber
dieses Gesetz ist ja sowieso also wir
fing von 12 Milliarden na das für die
Kinder Grundsicherung da ist ja keiner
dagegen ging ja nicht darum dass man
Renten irgendwie kürzen will oder so da
hätte ich ja Streit verstanden aber
Kinder Grundsicherung
[Musik]